what are your thoughts on um
on you know chicago's music scene the
last eight years nine years with the
drill [ __ ]
because the drill the drills so
when it first came out for me i i really
wasn't cause i'm like
i love the lyrical [ __ ] you know what i
mean like it was just
it it was it wasn't for me i mean i
loved it you know a lot of people have
different different perceptions of music
at different times so at that time
me listening to the music it's a lot of
different reasons
like you can listen to some of the drill
music and you'll see like damn from a dj
perspective adrenaline rush fits right
on top of it
right right same bpm yeah yeah so
definitely i'm locked in from that
perspective then i i saw two
as technology advanced and people got a
chance to open their laptops and see
how chicago really was from a chief
keith perspective and
little dirk and all of these guys right
here that's coming up doing their thing
and you're like wow
you know so now you got something new
that you never saw
that ad now we got another element added
on to hip hop
with this old dream oh for sure real
vibe in it and it and it kind of shifted
the way everybody is doing that music so
i love that because
you know like not only was i waiting on
chicago to just
come with that constant quality music
man once they started lighting it up man
i was like you know yeah i feel like big
fan whatever
whatever you want to say man like all is
influenced everything going on right now
like we just were in new york
interviewing uh all the brooklyn drill
rappers
and it was like all of them are just
straight yo i grew up listening to chief
keef
and dirk and g herbo and
yeah and all those guys too like shout
out to dirk shout out to g herbal like
those guys have evolved musically too
yeah that's right
yeah yeah and their talents have evolved
the young bulls they be killing it man i
love it
you love it what else um out of chicago
are you checking
like cause you know like i said there's
the other side of chicago you know
there's guys like vic mensah
i mean obviously chance has been on a
quite a run since about 2013 you know
like like yeah
vic spencer too it's a guy named vic
spencer in chicago that'd be killing it
too
really yeah oh vic spencer i thought you
said vic spencer like
vic spencer no chicago slang vic spencer
yeah yo what's going on with uh with the
crucial conflict guys man i
the last time i heard um i heard uh
i want to say it was was a wild style or
one of them dudes was on uh vic mensah
was a part of a group
called the kids these days
and they redid hey okay and i think the
dude was on and i was like yo i just i
love the final check they they still do
final tick was my [ __ ] yeah and they
still perform those records man you
you you definitely need to check out a a
crucial conflict show
one of the guys names is wild style was
one of his name was it never
yeah never i'm trying to remember if i
remember how style never cole hard
cole hart and kilo kilo yeah that [ __ ]
and that showdown record
yeah yeah that was a
tell you that album was a challenge
crucial conflict you did
what's up with uh the do or die guys
still doing shows
still doing their things yeah i do a lot
of records with them you know
yeah what would you like like like you
know because because uh
there was definitely a vibe about that
music y'all were making like
uh it was some because you know we think
of chicago
and i i remember as a kid seeing the
documentary like getting the documentary
from blockbuster that i forget which
pimpin documentary it was but you
remember they was doing pimping
documentaries in the 90s
yeah and i remember ice-t went to the
players ball
in chicago and there was like
all kinds of famous pimps there was like
mr white i can't even remember all the
pimps in this [ __ ] movie
but chicago is known for pimping for
that culture right yeah yeah
and and that vibe and that player [ __ ]
when that pop record got made
yeah and i felt like that the some of
those records were just they kind of
just fit that
vibe and it was something it was like
it's like it almost was like a real
midwest
like at the time there was west coast
there was east coast
and like like that was like to me like
what i what i kind of
computed as like midwest [ __ ] yeah i
mean it was everywhere though you you
definitely had it
you know out this way you know a lot a
lot for sure shout out to the bay yeah
yeah yeah but
but so i just feel like when you when
you
input that vibe in a certain place
i think it's uh just the aura you know
or the swag
of of the whole uh pimp culture you know
more so than anything just would affect
the music in a certain way
you know